[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So
let's get started today.
First of all, are there any
questions from last time?
All right.
Well, please feel free to
ask questions along the way.
In terms of the reading list,
we're up to lecture 9 today.
We're sharing with production.
It's our second lecture
on applications.
There are two starred papers.
And we're going to be
going through the first one
with Samphantharak
in detail, and then
a few selected slides on
the Kinnon et al paper.
But like all starred papers, I
hope you will be reading them,
because I know you're
very well trained now.
And you will be able
to read those articles.
So I think you would
get a lot out of it.
But we will cover
most of it today.
The other thing for
the study guide--
so let me ask you
guys some questions.
Last time was our first applied
lecture on risk sharing.
We did it in both village
India and medieval villages.
And today, I want to give
a little bit more emphasis
to the economics combined
with the analysis--
more than I usually do.
But it seems like
the time to do that,
since we're talking
about applications.
So the first one I picked here--
describe in words why villages
in India are a risky place,
how to quantify that
risk and its sources,
and how that risk might be
mitigated or potentially
mitigated via individual
or social diversification.
So I have lately been
taking volunteers.
But let me ask.
Dexin, do you want to
take a stab at that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So villages are a risky
place, because it's mostly
agriculture.
And it's not a stable
source of income.
And I think we can quantify
that risk by just looking
at the variation
through the years
and how it really changes,
and how a lot of things
are linked with each other
in terms of their risk.
And it can be
mitigated by planting
different kinds of plants,
or planting far apart--
that's individually.
And social diversification--
giving gifts or transfers.
Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Great.
Very, very good answer.
Thank you.
So we quantify the
risk by the coefficient
of variation of a given crop or
a given crop in a certain soil
type or a certain income source.
Just to add a few more details--
your answer was fine.
The covariance
across those things
actually helps
mitigate the risk.
And that's what
you're saying when
you said different crops or
different spots on the field.
Those are ex-ante.
So there's individual
things that people can do.
And the ex-post-- social
diversification is the gifts.
OK.
Next one.
Comparing incomes over
households and time
with consumption over
households and time,
what can you infer
from the data alone?
So let me stop there and
not read the second part.
Let's see.
Who would like to?
Charles, do you want
to take a stab at that?
Are you there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Let me think.
If I remember correctly,
this is something
like you can compare the
incomes, which is basically
the crop harvest, and then
what you end up receiving.
And I remember, you
can infer from--
you can see that it's
definitely much--
you end up getting is much
flatter than what's produced.
I guess I'm trying to answer
the second part of the question
now.
But that is data that suggests
that we're risk sharing.
I don't think that's
enough to prove causation,
but it's definitely suggestive.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, that's good.
Maybe the second sentence helps.
If average consumption
of households
increased when average income
of households increased,
would that be consistent
with risk sharing or not?
AUDIENCE: Oh, for me?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, for you.
AUDIENCE: So OK.
So OK, average consumption
has to increase, but--
I don't think it rolls out
to some sort of big sharing,
I don't think.
Because I think you have to
parse a degree of risk sharing
that wouldn't completely
annihilate everything.
But I don't think
that would be enough.
I think that would still be
consistent with some level,
right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
actually, the sentence
is not terribly well worded.
But it is worthwhile to clarify.
So the first part
that we looked at
is just the levels of stuff
over households and over time.
We referred to the
Rocky Mountain picture
as incomes going up
concealing the valley behind,
and very, very
jagged rocky pictures
as opposed to consumption,
which was very flat.
And we were even joking
around a bit-- very boring,
as in Kansas.
So then, the issue
would be with the theory
that we're about to look at.
Apart from the data
alone, would you
think household
consumption ought
to move with household income?
Actually, I think
there's a question below.
And what's ambiguous
about that sentence is,
household consumption is
increased with average income
of households.
Yeah, that's very
treacherously worded.
Average income meaning
overall the dates
of a given household--
that sets the levels of things.
And maybe the household with
higher average income over time
has a higher average
consumption over time.
And I'll ask for volunteers.
If we have this regression where
we run household consumption,
on the left, as the
dependent variable
onto aggregate consumption
and individual income,
on the right, throwing
in some intercepts-- so
what restrictions
from the theory
are placed on the coefficient
of individual income?
And I'll take a
volunteer for that.
AUDIENCE: I think the
coefficient individual income
should be 0, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's just related
to the aggregate in average
income of the household.
And I have a question here.
It's that I remember
in the slides--
saying that when all the
households have the same risk
aversion, then the coefficient
between the aggregate
consumption should be 1.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But why?
I think the coefficient
on the average consumption
should be when not the
aggregate consumption.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh,
well there's, say,
a fixed number of households.
So taking the
aggregate and dividing
by the number of households
gives you the average.
It's just a renormalization
of the units, that's all.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: But you're
right that it's meant
to represent the aggregate.
So you can think of it that way.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Because the
economics makes more sense.
The aggregate is
going up, coming up
over all the individuals.
And if there's constant absolute
risk aversion and the same risk
aversion for all the
households, then whenever
the aggregate goes up,
every individual household
consumption goes up 1 to 1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Which
is what you said.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
And the emphasis here is the
household-specific income.
It has a coefficient of 0.
That's the salient
restriction that the theory
places on the data as well.
And then finally, we looked
at the division of land
in these medieval village.
And the question
is, would scattering
of an individual
household's plots
across the different
fields be enough to achieve
an optimal allocation
of risk sharing?
Paolo, do you want to
take a crack at that?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I think the answer is no, just
because it's not necessarily
that each field
is a random draw.
You can have correlations
like, it's just a drought here
and there's no rain anywhere.
That's a risk, which would be
a shock to all of your crops,
essentially.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So it's correct that it's
not necessarily enough,
unless you have very
special characteristics
of those plots--
how they move with various
states of the world.
In the lecture, we
gave an example--
two examples, really--
one where there
are two types of land
and both are increasing
as the states increase.
And then, it would be enough
to have each household have
a share, a constant share
over the two types of land.
That would result in a
linear risk sharing schedule.
So for certain
utility functions,
including an examination of
the slope and the intercepts,
that would be enough.
So in special cases,
it might work.
But in general, you have
two different types of land.
And the output goes up in one.
It may go down in
the other, depending
on the state of the world,
in which case, handing out
shares of each type is not
going to work, necessarily.
And we explore that
further in the lecture.
So that whole lecture
culminated at the end
with an example where we
had more states of the world
than we had land types
and restricted them
to having shares of each type
as if they could not transfer
stuff around.
And it was clear that it
was constrained optimal.
Taking that allocation of land
with the harvest as given,
we could do better
by, add to welfare
by having exposed redistribution
of the grain via transfers.
OK.
So that's probably
enough of a review.
As always, there are many more
questions in the study guide.
And probably, spend
quite a lot of time
just deciding which
ones to ask in class.
You should look at all of them.
And let's get to lecture 9,
is what we're doing today.
And this is risk
sharing with production.
Three main topics, really.
Risk and return in
production-- and that part
is continuation of
some of the themes,
although we didn't really
put all the pieces together.
We had production in
the dynamics lecture.
We had risk as in yields
coming from land plots.
But we never talked about
inputs into land plots,
and associated
outputs, and so on.
So we'll put those
two pieces together.
Another feature
of this lecture is
that we're going to use
data on production but also
on consumption.
So both things will be there.
And this is illustrative of
how powerful this risk sharing
framework is.
It extends to more and more
complicated situations.
We're able to do more
and more with it.
And finally, I have
some words at the end
about social networks
and sharing risk,
and in particular, an
example that will remind you
for better or worse
of COVID, and what's
going on when people get
sick with the economics.
OK.
So this first starred
paper on the reading list
with Krislert Samphantharak.
It'll tie, if you
haven't guessed,
extensions of the theory
project selection.
So we studied a model with risk
and return in productive assets
in developing economies--
namely, Thailand.
We're going to measure
idiosyncratic and aggregate
risk premia.
Those words probably don't
make a whole lot of sense,
although we've been talking
about related things just now
with the risk sharing
regression, idiosyncratic
being household-specific
income, and aggregate
being aggregate consumption.
And we're going to be
able to quantify those two
different premia and analyze
what households are doing,
how exposed they are to risk.
And finally, in
principle, one could
take not just the
straight-out returns,
but risk-adjusted
returns and look
for patterns across households,
like whether poor households
are more vulnerable
or less vulnerable,
does education
matter, and so on.
So here's the model.
There are capital J
households indexed by j,
little j for an individual.
J is the number
for the aggregate.
There are I production
activities, little i, big I.
And you can think of those
production activities
as production sets or
production technologies.
The inputs are capital.
And I'll say some
words a bit later
about where labor and materials
and seed and other things went.
But for now, just
think of there being
a single input called capital.
And the outputs are in the same
units of a single consumption
good.
So we're going to be looking
at a household running
a portfolio of assets.
Now, actually, the way you
think about this in finance
is, you want to engage
in a certain activity.
You acquire the assets
necessary to do that activity.
And a household could be doing
one or multiple activities.
This will generate a return.
So we want to know how
well the project is doing
and whether it was
selected properly.
So you want to compare
the rate of return
to the best alternative
use of funds
except that here, we're
going to put risk in.
So it makes it much
more interesting.
In particular, these set
returns are stochastic.
And they can be
correlated over activities
and correlated over households.
So again, you can think
about the previous lecture
with village India,
although this
happens to be village Thailand
and its different kinds
of crops and different
soils, different income
sources, and so on.
So I mentioned early
on in lecture 1
that we were going
to go back and forth
between actual real agrarian
economies and associated
metaphors.
So we can talk about trees
bearing fruit literally
in the data.
But we can also
talk about a tree
as an asset in financial
markets, households'
whole assets.
And they pay dividends.
And there may be correlations
in stock returns.
So exactly the same
theory is being applied
to two very different settings.
And in fact, we're reverse
engineering in this paper.
We're taking measures of risk
reduction and risk premia that
have been applied to stocks
in the New York Stock Exchange
and applying it to
all these activities
across various households
in a typical Thai village.
OK.
So a little bit
more in notation.
We have F production
function for activity
I run by household J. And
it has as a single input
the level at which
it's capitalized,
the capital input in activity
I run by household J.
So we can sum overall activities
and sum overall households
and get an aggregate
production function.
So again, early on in one of
those lectures on production,
we talked about aggregating
two example production
sets into one.
So this is a version of that.
So the economy starts out
with an aggregate amount
of wealth, which is
coming from two sources.
One, the trees,
and two, the fruit.
Now, let me just say that as
is standard in a lot-- not all,
but a lot-- of
economic models, we're
going to have what we call a
putty putty, meaning that you
take the putty in terms of very
malleable consumption, what
could be consumption, and
invest it into capital.
And then, that yields a return.
You can certainly eat the fruit,
but you can also eat the tree.
So the putty putty part
comes from undoing the tree.
Of course, in many
actual situations,
you can't eat the machine.
But it's as if you
could sell the machine
and get the
consumption equivalent.
If you wanted to eat
all of it, you could.
And you'll see that right
now in the notation.
We're going to have, quote
unquote, "a social planner."
But of course, you
know now, that just
means that we're going
to have these programming
problems for the determination
of Pareto optimal allocation.
And we're going to act as
if the planner is doing it.
But it's really a
math problem that we
can solve to go back and forth
between solutions to the math
problem and various Pareto
optimal allocations.
So consumption of household
J at a given moment--
say a year-- the sources
of potential consumption
would be the fruit, how
much activity I is yielding
a fruit run by household J
as a function of previously
determined capitalization KIJ.
We sum overall I. And
we have the tree itself,
which as I've said now
could be potentially eaten.
But from these
available resources,
we can subtract off the
capitalization for next period.
Prime means tomorrow
or next year.
And KIJ is the level of capital
carried out from this year
into next year.
So this is like storage in
that dynamic medieval village
economy.
That's one activity.
Seed planted in the ground
is another type of activity.
This is a generalization.
And finally, we have
these transfers, tau.
These are going to be, among
other things, key control
variables of the
so-called planner,
adding potentially to the
resources of the household,
or if negative, taking away.
So then, we come to
this programming problem
for the determination of
Pareto optimal allocations.
And despite some heavy
looking notation,
you'll probably understand
this pretty readily.
First of all, here's the
utility function of household J.
And all the slide does is stick
into what would be consumption.
The consumption is
defined at the bottom
of the previous slide--
resources available
minus resources
utilized for next period
year plus the transfer.
These lambdas are
the Pareto weights
for maximizing a lambda-weighted
sum of utilities today.
And the control
variables for the planner
are these transfers,
as I've already said,
plus the level of capitalization
of all the projects.
So we're trying to find an
optimal allocation of capital
as well as an optimal
allocation of the transfers.
Small apology-- this
apostrophe-looking object
shouldn't be there
on top of the taus.
It's not a prime, because the
transfers are decided today,
not next period.
But there's definitely
a prime on this capital,
because the current state has
already given the projects
with their capitalizations.
The thing to be decided
upon is how much capital
you want to invest in all
the various possible projects
for tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: Is it is it better
to add a depreciation here?
Because if instead of a tree,
if you think of a machine?
It will definitely depreciate.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, it's
loaded into this output.
And you'll see this in the data.
You take net profits
but you subtract off
as an expense the depreciation.
But it's true it's
not there explicitly,
but that's where it is.
So yeah, it should be
and it is included, OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Now the other
thing that makes this thing
complicated-- but again, you're
already tooled up to get this
right away--
these are these value functions.
So what is the state
of the world today?
It's total wealth that's
available at the bottom
of the slide summing over all
activities and households,
all fruit and all trees.
This capital lambda is just
the individual Pareto weights.
And they're fixed for all time.
And then, you decide on
these control variables
how much to eat and
how much to save
in the various technologies.
That's going to deliver
a state for tomorrow,
which is wealth tomorrow.
It would be W prime.
Just like W is this period, W
prime would be for next period.
And you would have a prime
on all of these objects.
You'd have the fruit in the
trees next period at prime.
That's the W prime.
This value function
is as if they lived
in an infinite horizon economy.
They're discounting
next period by this fee.
Usually, we use beta.
But beta in this lecture is
reserved for something else,
like a regression coefficient.
So fee is the common discount
rate across all the households.
And you remember how
we got these Vs, right?
We had a slide at the
end of one of the--
at the dynamic lecture.
Act like it's a finite period.
So for the optimum, which would
be, don't fund everything,
eat everything in sight.
And then, go to the next
to last period and third
to last period.
And then, keep
iterating as far back
into the present as possible.
And this value function,
which would have a T on it
for the length of horizon,
will go to something stable,
as if we had solved the
infinite horizon problem.
So that's all loaded
up in here, too.
Questions about this slide?
Oh, one last thing.
You can't put negative
capital into the ground.
Capital could be
0, in which case
you're not doing that activity.
Or it's positive, in which case
you are doing the activity.
This is true over all projects
I in all households J.
You can set that thing up as
a Lagrangian with the shadow
prices and solve.
And you'll get a
familiar condition.
If you differentiate
with respect
to consumptions or the
transfers, for that matter,
you will get that these lambda
weighted margin utilities
should be the same
over all households
and equal to a common
Lagrange multiplier
on the current
resource constraint mu.
So you've actually
seen this before.
It's exactly equal to what
we had before in village
India without consideration
of production.
But we're going to
get something else.
Namely, when we look
at the control variable
the capital control
variables, we're
going to get something that
links marginal utility today
to effectively to marginal
utility next period.
And that is that
the lambda weighted
marginal utility of consumption
today for household J--
if this were set equal--
should be equal to the
future margin utility.
Well, if you take a
unit of resource today
infinitesimally small,
and instead of eating it
you invest it, what
you'll get tomorrow
would be the derivative
off the production
function of that investment.
Plus you get the tree
back, that one unit back.
And that return stream
is going to be evaluated
at the marginal
utility of wealth,
which is the derivative of this
value function at tomorrow's
wealth.
So again, we're just
taking a derivative
of this right-hand side term.
Questions?
So it's written as
a weak inequality.
It could be less than 0.
If it's less than 0, let's
take the margin utility
of consumption today,
which is minus,
and on the left-hand side,
put it on the right-hand side.
And that would say, the
weighted margin utility
of consumption today is strictly
greater than the margin utility
you would get tomorrow.
So they're going
to hit a corner.
They would like, actually, the
capital level to go negative,
because they're
desperate to eat today.
The marginal utility
return today is higher
than it will be next period.
But of course,
we're not allowing
them to go negative,
hence the inequality.
To remind you in other
contexts, we write out
the full Lagrangian program.
We put an extra
Lagrange multiplier
on these non-negativity
constraints.
Then this whole thing
would be at an equality.
But it would have as well
the potentially positive
Lagrange multiplier.
Anyway, the conclusion is, not
all activities need be funded.
You might actually want to
unfund them and draw resources
out of them that aren't there.
You can't do that.
So you set them equal to 0.
Others get funded
at a positive level.
We will be focusing
a lot on these set
of activities over households
for which this is equal to 0.
And those are funded projects.
OK, so it looks like this
is entirely closed economy.
But as I said, these
techniques generalize.
So we can think of a village
as a small open economy.
And maybe they can
go to an outside bank
and borrow money,
in which case we'd
have to change the wealth
variable to subtract off
the principal and interest
that's coming due today,
but add in the debt that
they enter into today.
That will come due
the next period.
Nothing changes.
These first order
conditions don't change.
Oh, it's good for them
in terms of smoothing.
If the village wealth is
low, the village as a whole
might want to borrow.
That's fine.
So the quantitative
solution can change,
but our characterization in
terms of these first order
conditions will not change.
So we do not need to
assume a closed economy.
All right.
So what the heck is this?
Well, this mu is the lambda
weighted marginal utility.
I substituted that into
this left-hand side
of the second expression,
set it equal to 0.
And then, you've got two terms.
Dividing through
by this, you would
set everything equal to 1.
So it's actually easier
to look at the algebra
than it is to say it in words.
We take mu here and
divide this term
by mu, which makes
it equal to unity,
and the second term
by mu, which is
what is being displayed here.
And then, the rest is
algebra, although it's
revealing that we can
take this expectation
operator outside the
whole expression,
that these returns are random.
I'm not sure I've been
emphasizing that enough.
It looked like constants,
because you just
have the level of capital.
But the return on a unit
of capital is random.
Where did that first
start to happen?
I should have said it right here
when we had that expectation
operator.
So anyway, bring the
expectation operator out
in front of everything.
And then, adopt some very
cryptic notation, M--
actually, M prime-- for this
term, which is essentially
the discounted Lagrange
multiplier next period
divided by the Lagrange
multiplier today.
So that's a discount factor.
Call it M prime, and
this R, capital R,
is the total return on
the project being run,
the activity R run
by household J.
The return-- you get the tree
back, plus you get the fruit.
And this is a prime here.
It's the marginal
return, obviously.
Because when we looked at
the first order condition,
we were varying the
level of capital.
So we picked up a derivative
in the production function.
So this is just notation.
But it's very
convenient notation.
So it's saying that
for all activities
R run by households J, this
product, this expected product,
is equal to 1.
Furthermore, looking at
that expected product,
there's a result in
statistics that we
didn't put into the
lecture on uncertainty.
But it's easy enough
to state, which
is, expectation of
two random variables
is equal to the product of
the expectations adjusted
by the covariance of
the two variables.
If the covariance is 0, then
these individual variables
are independent.
And it's just the product
of the expectations.
But the covariance
is an easy way
to adjust if they're
not independent.
So now, we just
substitute in that formula
in the previous slide, which
had this expression on the left.
We now substitute in the
expression on the right
and manipulate by dividing
through this expectation of M
prime.
And we get this object here.
So the expected return on
activity I run by household J--
expected return next period--
has an intercept in some
kind of product term.
And I'm about to give you
an interpretation of what
these are.
And in some respects,
this beta is going
to be a regression coefficient.
And the lambda is going to
be a measure of social risk.
In particular, finally, if
we imagine those production
functions are linear, then
the return on activity
I run by household J is
linear in the capital.
Constant returns to scale.
However, as I have been
trying to say, this return--
this little r thing--
is a random variable.
Anyway, the marginal
return is that little r.
So also, it's the average
return, for that matter.
And we can talk about the
growth rate of return equal 1
plus the net rate of return
as a definition of capital R.
Just so you might feel a bit
more comfortable, if we have
a constant returns to scale
production function actually
finally modeling other inputs
like labor and materials
and so on, if you optimize that
and put the optimized inputs
back into the
function, you would
get this derived function, which
is linear in the capital stock.
So that's where
it's coming from.
But I didn't give
you that algebra.
Secondly, what
about preferences?
Let's let the value
function be quadratic.
So you've seen these before.
W star is a bliss point.
And less than W star--
so that the marginal
utility of wealth
is always strictly positive.
So if we go back to this guy
here and start substituting
in what we assumed about the
production function and utility
function, then
we're actually going
to get an expression which says,
the average or expected return
on household J's activities
less the risk free rate
is equal to beta J
for household J times
the expected return
in the whole village
minus the risk free rate.
In fact, you can put this R
prime F, the risk free rate,
on the right-hand side.
So that would be the constant.
So it's constant plus
theta times this guy.
And let me define these
terms a little bit.
R prime J no longer
has an I on it,
because it's the weighted return
over all the activities run
by household J. Likewise, the
return for the whole village--
market, if you like--
M, is the weighted
average return
over all activities
and all households.
So you take the
capitalization of activity
I run by household J, look at
the return on that as a peer
activity I run by household
J, sum over for the household
all activities I, sum
over all households J,
you're getting a total
return over all activities
in all households.
And to get a rate of
return, you divide
by the level of capitalization.
And the total level
of capitalization
is just the sum of the
capitals over all activities
and projects.
And what is this beta?
This beta is just a covariance
divided by a variance.
As I've said, it's going to
be a regression coefficient.
If you're used to
ordinary least squares,
you know that a
regression coefficient
is x prime x inverse x prime y.
So x must be in the
denominator here,
which means that we're running
on the right-hand side,
the total market village return.
And on the left-hand side,
the dependent variable
is going to be the
return of household J.
So we're going to regress
the return of household J
over all the periods
of the sample
onto the aggregated
village level return
and get a regression
coefficient.
And that's going to
be beta J. And that's
going to capture how much the
activities run by household J
are covarying with what the
village is doing as a whole.
Now, as I think I
explained to you last time,
I could go from here to here.
And it would all just look
like some kind of claim.
Go see the paper.
If you don't read the paper,
it remains mysterious.
You have an extra
level of abstraction.
You don't believe the results.
So I actually wrote
in the algebra.
I am not going to
go through it today,
because it is nothing
other than algebra.
But it's how to take
those two assumptions
about quadratic utility
and production functions,
and actually manipulate the
equations we already had,
substituting in these
particular expressions
and getting, at the
bottom, the expression that
corresponds to this, OK?
But I'm going to skip that.
So again, mechanically, take
the return of household J
at year T. Regress it onto
constant and onto the time
series of the market return.
And this is actually
a prime here.
We're having trouble editing
these latex files, I guess.
So this is a prime.
So we have prime.
This could be all today,
today, or it could
be next period, next period.
Just be consistent about it.
So the return of household
J at day T regressed
on to the village level
return at dates T,
running over all T.
So the sample could--
I'll show you in a minute--
something like 10 years
of data, a bit more.
Plus, an epsilon
is the error term.
After you run this
regression using the time
series for each
household, one at a time,
and having estimated
these beta Js,
we now run the next
regression, which is entirely
cross-sectional regression.
We compute for each
household the average return
over the entire sample, which
is a proxy for the household's
expected return, the
data analog to that.
And we regress that for each
household J onto its beta J
as derived in the
first equation-- so 1.
So the economics here is,
the return on the project
run by household J, the
expected return, should equal,
say roughly, the risk free rate.
But it has a risk premium--
first time I've use that
now with the notation.
And the risk premium has
to do with the comovement
of household J's activity
with the village aggregate.
So we talked about
diversification
at the beginning of class.
And the idea here is, if the
things household J is doing
are highly correlated
with returns
on what other people are
doing, then household J
isn't doing very
much worthwhile.
Household J is not diversifying
the village level risk.
So in order to justify
the set of activities
that household J is
doing, we have to bump up
its expected rate of return.
In some sense, we use
the word risk premium,
meaning household J's
activities are pretty risky.
Why?
Because they're correlated
with the village average.
So diversification
is not-- and we
need to compensate for that
lack of diversification.
The opposite is more
revealing, perhaps,
which is, if this
correlation is low or even 0,
it's a wonderful hedge.
Even if not many households
are doing those things,
if household J does them and
manages to produce a return
stream, which is not so
correlated with the return
streams of the other households,
that's great, in which case,
we don't need to have
a high risk premium.
Because actually,
it's reducing risk.
So that's the economics of it.
It's all, also, entirely here
in terms of the equations.
All right.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I have a question
about a previous slide.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So it's more
like econometrics stuff,
because I think there should
be some estimation error here,
because the beta is estimated.
And in step 2, you just regress.
You regressive return on
some estimated beta, right?
So you just regress some true
data, or some estimated data?
And I think the lambda here
will have some error rate.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, there
are two things to adjust for.
One, this is a
regression coefficient.
So it is measured with error.
It has a standard error.
And we do adjust the
beta that we're using
to allow for that uncertainty.
That's part of
what you're asking.
Is that what you're
asking about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, probably.
But yeah, OK.
OK, yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The other
thing is that here, we're
regressing an individual J
return on the village average.
So you do have to be
worried about regressing
dependent variables on the
left with their average
on the right.
And that tends to bias
this beta toward 1.
That's another
econometric problem,
except that here, we're actually
interested in dispersion
across the different betas.
So we're OK.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: And
this is Fama, French,
which I suspect you know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
know that, yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So we're just doing what they
did with the New York stocks--
doing it here in the
Thai villages, OK?
We started our survey in
1998 with a big baseline.
We update it every
month thereafter.
This said, at the time we
were writing the paper,
the survey was still
ongoing, although even then,
the later months were not ready.
So we ended up using
monthly data from month 5
to month 160 of the survey.
The other thing that's
misleading-- it's
not ongoing anymore.
The project ended
about 18 months ago.
But we did end up with almost
20 years of monthly data.
So it's a vast warehouse
of potential projects
that can be done with it.
And I'm happy to tell you more.
But today, I want to
focus on this paper.
So we only included
the households
that were actually in the
village for the whole period.
Sometimes, entire households
picked up stakes and leave.
We excluded them.
We also are looking
only at households
with production activities.
Farm is included, but also
fish, shrimp, livestock, trade
and handicrafts.
But not just wage earnings--
why?
Because with wage
earnings, they're
not really producing anything.
They're earning something
by working for others.
So they're not entrepreneurs.
So we did not include them.
And there are extensive networks
of family in these villages.
And I'm going to come back
to that a little bit later
toward the end.
So just to give you a
feeling of the data,
we've got net income,
which means income
from household enterprise.
It's the difference
between revenue and costs
of all the inputs.
Revenue is realized at the time
of sale, or if it's a crop,
it could be eaten.
It could be given as a gift
from others at all counts.
We add them all up.
Revenue even comes from
renting out assets.
We include that.
Costs are all the inputs
used in production,
whether they're acquired
in cash or in-kind
with credit or gifts.
We count them all.
We put a valuation
on them if it's not
acquired in the market.
So we take revenue minus
costs, include depreciation--
that came up earlier.
Subtract it.
And we get net income.
And these assets
we're talking about--
we have agricultural,
business, livestock assets.
We've also got land
and household assets.
The agricultural assets,
to give you an example,
includes walking tractors--
you might remember
in the production lecture, I
showed you a picture of that
guy walking around
with the tractor--
or larger four wheel tractors,
aerators for ponds, machines
to put seeds in the
ground, machines
like sprinklers, et cetera.
So you're in the village now.
You can imagine
living there, I think.
This is the level of
detail that we have.
We did put household assets in.
That's a decision, because
some of the things that
look like a durable good end
up being used in farming,
like a pickup truck.
They use it.
So rather than-- but we've
done robustness checks.
But here, we include
them all, OK?
So let me just jump here.
If we look at that data,
this is the return on assets,
the expected return on household
J. Each J corresponds to a dot
here.
And it's just the average
return for household J.
On the y-axis and the beta,
the regression coefficient
on the village average
is on the x-axis.
So you can see that households
that have higher returns
are households that have higher
betas for three of the four,
potentially all four, although
Buriram is not the greatest
example.
And I have shown
this picture to guys
working in finance with New York
Stock Exchange or Swedish Data.
And they see this
degree of correlation.
And they're like, wow,
that's really amazing.
So the theory is
working pretty well.
And this is the regression.
Doesn't really add more.
This is the regression from that
step 1 with the corresponding--
sorry, step 2, it is, with
the corresponding betas.
And it's not
significant in Buriram,
but it is in the
other three provinces.
Not sure if I've
shown you this map.
I don't think we did.
Chachoengsao and Lopburi are
relatively near to Bangkok.
And Buriram and Srisaket are
out in the agrarian regions
of the northeast.
So very different
types of sample.
OK, so let's talk about
idiosyncratic risk.
The return on household
J is determined by beta J
that we've been talking about.
X is to make the
argument more general.
So regression coefficient
times the object,
and then an error term.
So if you take the variance
of both sides doing
a variance decomposition,
the variance of the return
is the variance explained
by the dependent variable
with its coefficient plus the
variance of the error term.
So when we talk about
idiosyncratic risk,
we're talking about the
error term here as opposed
to how much of the variance
is determined by the village
aggregate.
And so you can just imagine
taking this variance term
and dividing it
through both sides.
And then, you'll
have one like, 100%
is equal to the
contribution of the village
return plus the contribution
of the idiosyncratic
variance to the total.
So this is not theory.
This is a way of quantifying
how much aggregate village
average risk there is and how
much idiosyncratic risk there
is in an individual J's return.
Now, the next thing--
back to the regression--
as I have been saying,
in the baseline,
we're running the average
return on household J
onto a constant plus the beta
J coefficient times beta J.
And now, we do something extra.
We add in sigma J,
where sigma J here
is the variance of
this epsilon term.
How much is it moving--
oh, it's right here,
except that I didn't
call it sigma J here.
The variance of epsilon
J is sigma J. Stick
that into this
cross-sectional regression
as an extra right-hand
side variable.
And get a coefficient on it.
So now, we can do a
similar calculation.
We can take the
risk premium, which
is the sum of both the return
over above the risk free rate
that's due to the
aggregate return
and also due to the
idiosyncratic risk.
And so we can decompose
the aggregate risk
as a proportion of the
total, and likewise,
the idiosyncratic risk as
a proportion of the total.
Question?
So doing that, we
summarize the results--
the contribution
of idiosyncratic
risk to total risk
and the contribution
of idiosyncratic risk
to the risk premium.
The contribution of
idiosyncratic risk
to the total variance is huge.
This row here running
across the villages
and looking at the quartiles
including the median,
you've got 98% of it,
97% of it, 94% of it.
65% of the risk is coming from
the idiosyncratic component,
coming from this guy.
Let me back up.
Coming from this guy.
Second row of this
table is a contribution
to the risk premium of
the idiosyncratic risk.
And it's pretty small.
Two things to note--
it's almost always
lower than the quantity.
So the risk premium
here is also small.
Here, it's 21%,
which isn't trivial.
Or even here, 45%.
But the 45% is still
less than the 99%.
So the contribution
to the risk premium
in terms of the compensating
returns required
for the household to run
those technologies is always--
the contribution
to the total risk
is always greater
than the risk premium.
Except Buriram
screws up over here.
But as you've seen, Buriram
screws up in other ways.
And then, we do a
robustness check.
Question?
OK, back to the economics.
And in medieval villages
scattered around,
random returns.
Should they diversify?
Do they do different
activities, et cetera?
Well, that depends
on the level of risk.
And it turns out, there's a
lot of risk, but a lot of it
is plot-specific or
activity-specific.
Most of it is idiosyncratic
and not aggregate.
It is not true that the
returns are comoving much
across all these activities.
So it's a very risky
place, as in India.
But there are plenty of
diversification possibilities
by holding multiple
activities, et cetera.
So we're back to a
version of what we did
in medieval villages, right?
How much did they
hold different plots?
Here, we are asking, how much do
they hold different activities
and what can be
accomplished by doing that?
And moreover, since
it's idiosyncratic,
you can hope that it might get--
the risk premium for
the idiosyncratic stuff
might get small.
Anyway, all of this is
from the production data.
Let's look at the consumption
data, and in particular,
look at the gifts.
So now, we're going
from medieval villages,
so to speak, in terms
of plots and production,
to India in terms of ex-post
consumption smoothing.
The gifts and transfers
are the ex-post part.
It's how much they would give
money to each other starting
from--
do actually give
money to each other--
starting from the yields on
their production activities.
So if you look back here again,
you would see these epsilons.
So this could be high.
This could be low.
If the variance is big it's
moving the returns around.
What happens when
it's really big?
Then, this household got lucky.
It had a high return.
Just lucky.
What does it do?
It gives stuff away.
Or another version--
they get unlucky.
The epsilon is low.
What do they do?
People give them gifts.
Well, I haven't actually
shown your result.
But that's exactly what
is going on in the data.
So if you regress those shocks,
those idiosyncratic shocks
on the right-hand side onto
gifts and net lending, et
cetera, you can see both.
There is an ultimate
impact on consumption, yes,
but it's small
relative to the way
they're mitigating the risk.
Namely, when the
shock is high, they're
giving stuff away
and lending it out.
And conversely, when
the shock is low,
they're getting this stuff in.
It depends on the sign.
This is net gift outflow
when the shock is high.
It's positive.
It's statistically significant.
You can add up both gifts
and borrowing and lending
and get a bigger
coefficient here.
It's 40.
So 40 relative to the impact
on consumption, which is 4.
In other words, for every
unit of idiosyncratic shock,
roughly 10% of it is making
its way into consumption,
which it shouldn't.
It violates the
risk sharing theory.
But 90% of it is being
pooled away by this village
gift-giving mechanism.
Questions?
In economics, we call
this the smoking gun.
You theorize a lot.
You think you know
what happened.
But what's the evidence?
Well, they smoothed a lot.
Must be the gifts.
OK, fine.
If you think so.
Well, here's the evidence.
They're actually doing it.
And not only that, they openly
tell us they're doing it.
They are very aware that
they help each other.
I think you might have seen
the video by now-- my movie,
so to speak.
If not, take a look at it.
Because it describes--
you'll actually
see the setting of
these Thai villages
and how we've gathered
the data, and so on.
Michael is planning to
show that at one point.
But it's available.
It's a 32-minute movie.
It's not so much of a burden.
And you'll see how I
spend 20 years of my life.
OK, so we've talked
about in this.
Now, let's come back
to health shocks.
No, it's not COVID.
But it is an illness
experienced by the household.
And it's not covered
by insurance.
And the expenditures go up.
So this is normalized so
that the event happens here.
And health spending is
big, and other things like,
they say they're sick.
They're reporting
symptoms to us.
We also measure that.
So we're pretty
much sure that we
nailed the episode, et cetera.
And sick days goes up
and stays up for a while
before it comes back down again.
OK.
And what happens?
There come the gifts.
Again, centered around
the episode, the event.
As soon as the event happens,
it's actually minus 1.
As soon as the event
happens, the gifts
are positive and
statistically different
than for households that did not
experience those health shocks.
Here, we're comparing placebo
households, if you like,
which is a dangerous
metaphor given the illness
part of it and the COVID.
We're taking households pairwise
conceptually-- one set have
experienced these health
shocks, and ones that have not,
and looking at the difference
in the gifts that they get.
So if they're sick,
they're much more
likely to be getting
gifts than the others.
This is the same setting
as what I showed you
in rates of return, except we've
changed the subject from shocks
to production to illness shocks.
Now actually related, they're
still producing or trying to.
And the fact that
they've doubled,
say, their health expenditure
is a big problem for them.
Because they have only
so much liquidity.
And they're supposed
to be buying inputs
and so on to fund their
agriculture and so on.
So this is a liquidity shock.
It's not just a health shock.
In fact, sometimes,
it's an elderly person
in the household
that is not even
contributing to production.
So we're looking at
the economic impact
of someone taking money away
from their budget, essentially.
OK, there are various kinds
of networks in these villages.
This is the kinship network,
who's related to whom.
This is the financial
network in terms
of giving gifts to one another.
This is the sales network, who
they sell to in the village.
And this is who they hire from.
So the way these
pictures are produced
with the software,
roughly speaking,
households in the
middle are connected
to many other households.
Households on the fringe don't
have that many connections,
depending on the variable.
And the gift giving
financial network
is different from the sales
and production network.
And I'm going to show you
what happens because of that.
I don't have a slide
to show you this,
but if they're in this gift
giving network measured
by how many times they
got gifts before the shell
shock happened, then most
of the impact of the shock
is covered by incoming gifts.
But what do we have in the US?
This is an issue.
A household gets sick.
Is the government going
to be able to help them?
We have these PPP Paycheck
Protection Programs and so on.
Are relatives helping?
Probably so.
We don't know the extent of it.
It's not measured.
We tend to think
households are standalone.
They're vulnerable.
Households running
businesses in particular
get a liquidity shock.
And mainly, they don't
have sales with COVID.
Or their employees
aren't able to work.
So they're not
generating revenue.
Well, if it were
covered with gifts,
as it is for some
people in Thailand,
then they pool that risk away.
Great system.
If they're not, there
are other consequences.
So in particular,
we can look at who's
connected to whom in
terms of the network.
Households who experience
shocks and were
selling to other households--
their sales go down.
It's a bit counterintuitive,
because you
would think they would want
the money from the sales.
But the problem is, they
had to reduce the inputs.
They had to scale
production down.
And so they have less
revenue as a result.
Sales are down.
Inventories are up.
Well, I should-- let me
come back and clarify.
These are households connected
to the household that
has experienced a shock.
These guys were selling--
I said it wrong.
I'm sorry.
These guys were selling
revenue to the household
that had the shock.
Now, they sell less.
Likewise, because
they sell less,
they're accumulating inventory.
And they're holding
onto inventory longer.
This is this inventory
turnover ratio.
That's a measure of--
I'm going to [? tie it-- ?]
It's a measure of inefficiency.
It's also negative
with an adverse effect.
We do this for all the shocks
and do it for the large shocks.
So now, we see the
COVID connection,
which is, a household
experiences expenses associated
with the illness, even if
it's not a working member.
How do they cover
those expenses?
They try to cut back.
They cut back on spending.
In these village economies,
businesses are connected.
They're buying and selling
inputs from one another,
and selling output.
So if they have to cut back
and they don't have the revenue
that they had before, the
people who had been buying
had been selling to them
no longer have the sales.
Just like one business
is connected to another,
they all go down
the supply chain,
because they're connected.
We had a lecture at the
end on interconnections
among households.
We did Leontief.
We did the input output matrix.
I showed you Fukujima
and Shima, and the effect
of the earthquake there.
And those were
all supply chains.
One sector is
connected to another.
One firm's connected to another.
These Thai households
are connected to another.
And the point of this--
I guess I haven't said that--
is, yet, the closer they
are to the adversely
impacted household,
the more they suffer.
So you think networks
are good things.
Networks are a
good thing when it
comes to financial gift giving.
But if gift giving doesn't
cover the adverse shock,
we're actually getting
an amplification
in this economy
that's showing up
in terms of lost wages and less
production, and less sales.
And finally, this
distinction, which I've
been pushing today, about
aggregate and idiosyncratic
shocks--
go to one of the
areas, Chachoengsao,
where they have fish ponds,
shrimp ponds in particular.
And it's pretty polluted.
And they didn't have green
agriculture, so to speak.
And the EU put a
ban on the shrimp.
By the way, if you
go to Walmart--
you say, villages?
Who cares?
Well anyway, they produce the
shrimp that you buy in Walmart.
But the EU put a
ban on the shrimp,
because they say it wasn't
clean, which it wasn't.
Now, the point is, most
but not all households
are doing those shrimp ponds.
And the ban is like
an aggregate shock.
So we can compare
the aggregate shock,
which is most of the households,
to the idiosyncratic illness
shocks.
And you can see that
although gifts go up--
I already showed you that--
for the idiosyncratic shocks,
including in this village,
there's not that
clear picture when
it comes to the shrimp shock.
Because it's an aggregate shock,
there's not a lot of ways--
excuse me-- to
reallocate that risk.
And this is the
associated decline
in employment, which is bigger
under the aggregate shock.
OK, questions?
OK.
That's what I have for today.
And we'll continue on Thursday.
Thank you for coming today.
Talk to you soon.